[Musica]
quando mi hanno invitato chiara uno
specifico ragazza dell'organizzazione ho
detto no faccio sempre per vedere se i
ragazzi tengono davvero a quello che va
da fare per te che poi quando me l'ha
richiesto del detto assolutamente no era
detto devi parlare davanti alla
telecamera registra però se sono qui è
perché me l'ha chiesto una terza volta
proprio perché non si è arresa si vedeva
tg tenero e paparo che conoscevo tutti i
ragazzi dell'organizzazione vedevo che
nei loro chi c'era quella scintilla
quella voglia di cambiare pubblica in
modo si cambia così si inizia a cambiare
se stessi
poi si agisce nella propria famiglia qui
si cerca di migliorare la propria scuola
e quindi la pubblicità è così che si
cambia il podio passava e tutti quanti
dobbiamo fare il nostro scarpe da solo
che questi ragazzi stanno facendo la
loro barca parte che quando vi parlavano
del progetto e trapano alla memoria la
fase di più
filosofo francese dei primi del
novecento accesi adesso dopo che era
verso la svizzera ci stanno spazi quindi
li posso citare che dice ogni persona ha
un ruolo all'interno dell'universo delle
persone e insostituibile che gli dà una
magnifica grandezza unità pari a un
universo e contemporaneamente la sua
piccolezza perché ogni persona uguale
all'altra e le persone sono più numerose
delle stelle questo spiega il concetto
complicato di persona cioè unica
irripetibile
eppure piccola ecco perché non possiamo
essere ridotti ai libri
ok e coccoli pp turismo è secondo lui
individualismo è una tragica solitudine
cui vessa l'uomo mentre la persona
agisce con altruismo si lega agli altri
rapporto di interesse stile dote del
sito qualcosa per avere qualcosa in
cambio
l'individuo agisce maniera egoista e
pagherà autobotti
si difende per gatti
tutti e due hanno dei boschi sia
l'individuo che la persona hanno degli
obiettivi da raggiungere ma mentre
l'individuo non guarda alle ricadute
delle sue azioni verso gli altri e porta
get alla persona ti interessa perché la
persona agisce guardando al bene comune
la vera discriminante per le azioni di
una persona e l'amore è quello che mi fa
scegliere di volta in volta che voglio
diventare davvero la persona che voglio
essere davanti a un video morale davanti
a ogni decisione la persona decide chi
vuole essere un processo di auto
plasmato e questo processo è ben
visibile tipacci docente lo dico di
quella fascia d'età che va dai 12 ai
vent'anni quando cioè i ragazzi se
persone sono alla ricerca costante della
verità su se stessi sugli altri sulla
propria singolarità su quello che
possono offrire alla vita e si accorgono
di non poterlo fare da soli infatti
questo periodo sono accompagnati dai
genitori dai coetanei certo ma anche
dagli insegnanti che per questo devono
accorgersi delle norme sforzi che vanno
questi ragazzi ogni giorno lo scenario
ci presenta una dizione la crisi
all'interno del quale si muovono ragazzi
sforzo da parte nel pacific anzi da
soffiare a qualche influencer di turno
vincendo a scoprire davvero se stessi
dall'altra parte c'è l'impegno a non
chiudersi qui guardando gli altri
semplicemente come un nemico come
qualcuno da utilizzare magari per
raggiungere un obiettivo
l'altro diventa invece il fine ma il
mezzo per la persona appiglio a cui
aggrapparsi anche nei momenti difficili
della nostra vita e o lo studente
comprende che l'insegnante è uno di
quegli appigli oppure l'insegnante
rimane ingranaggio in ente all'interno
di un sistema che produce individui per
una società anonima e sterile
l'apertura verso l'altro l'amore del
docente per i suoi studenti e per
l'insegnamento spesso non è un
sentimento i sentimenti sono passeggeri
dovrebbe essere l'essenza principale da
cui derivare tutto il resto dovrebbe far
riscoprire all'alunno la gioia la
gratuita
l'epica del contatto con gli altri e con
la natura soprattutto in questo periodo
è così rischia qualcosa di nuovo le
classi dirigenti da secoli arruolano le
forze lavoro le menti più brillanti e
sfruttano quelle risorse naturali e
culturali ha alcun rispetto
l'oppressione poliziotto nome che è
sicuramente uno degli aspetti del
dominio globale che trova la sua base
proprio in quelle istituzioni come la
scuola oppure quella cultura di massa
che paradossalmente oggi viene chiamata
social è nata la scuola dovrebbe
impegnarsi per liberare la persona e il
suo spirito restituirgli quella
iniziativa il controllo sui propri scopi
è così che si crea una società del tutto
nuova è al centro di questa società come
fulcro principale di questa società
troveremo la persona con le sue esigenze
per fare questo c'è bisogno di gestire
tempo ed energia
e così si costruisce dialogo tra docente
e alunno però su un piano di parità di
per scoppio di reciproco arricchimento
la comunicazione infatti non è un
monologo spesso siamo abituati
arriva il docente in classe parla agli
studenti gestiti ad ascoltare o no la
lealtà la complicazione nasce come
dialogo fra persone aiuta questo dialogo
a un file dalla propria solitudine ci si
apre alla verità che diventa col docente
comune ricerca della verità e
l'obiettivo finale è questo che dà la
collettività perché se ci guardiamo
negli occhi
stiamo a vedere che gli altri hanno
delle esigenze
lavorare con loro per questo sigenze la
questione la collaborazione e il dialogo
dello scudetto in cerca crescita di copi
lenza dello studente in questo rapporto
dialogante col docente ritrova se stesso
e il docente contemporaneamente riscopre
la sua essenza originaria del ruolo di
levatrice socratica che non si
sostituisce alla mano assist e lo
accompagna verso la maturità non si
impegna esclusivamente a dargli del
sapere per creare individui eruditi ma
passi citare il senso critico chi lo
aiuta a combattere quel disco
contemporaneo che rifiuta completamente
il senso della vita di oggi la prima
esperienza che fa un bambino e la madre
la prima esperienza che uno studente
della società e docenti e questo ruolo
lo stack di parad assaporare che la
società non è semplicemente
competitività bene l'azione e man mano
che cresce in test è sempre più
relazioni sempre più importanti che lo
aiutano a comprendere anche il suo posto
all'interno del grande organismo
collettivo in maniera armonica e l'altro
fa più paura perché in alto
l'approccio alieno diverso da cui
difendermi da cui difendermi erigendo
muri promulgando leggi diventa qualcuno
da conoscere assistere a mare ed alta
cambiare difficile cambiare difficile
perché noi docenti siamo abituati a
utilizzare degli schemi vecchi di capaci
di interagire col mondo in continuo
divenire per rimaniamo fedeli a questi
schemi perché sono delle modalità con le
quali noi siamo stati istruiti dai
soggetti e o soggetti prima di noi
quando entro in una classe cola chiedo
allora a tutti i ragazzi
iscrivere immediatamente chi vogliono
essere risposta il lavoro che farò da
grande ma io non l'ho chiesta quel
perché lo fanno più abituati a
riflettere pensare
dobbiamo smetterla di pensare di usare
kendo c'è che sia semplicemente un vaso
pieno di sapere che deve riversare tutto
quello che ha all'interno dei bicchieri
più piccoli non badando invece ha fatto
che ogni bicchiere a una forma diversa
un colore diverso un futuro di renzo dei
sogni diversi
questa è la metafora che ho trovato
questa metafora dei bicchieri software o
meglio però mi serviva proprio per
spiegare i ragazzi legamenti e
differenti e possiamo comprendere
specialmente attraverso il dialogo
accettare oggi di dialogare con i
ragazzi significa soprattutto nelle
stanze a come lo studente pensa o quando
lo stesso sa questa è la vera sfida del
momento oggi può prendere di questi
ragazzi spesso e permettergli di
realizzarsi grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]